con sonrisas aplausos y abrazos de
Victoria así a celebraron los líderes de
las zonas separatistas de Ucrania y la
misma Rusia la victoria de los
referendos de acción
ahora podemos decir totalmente
razonablemente el don Bass es Rusia lo
fue y lo será con apoyos entre el 87% y
el 99% en las cuatro zonas en las que se
realizaron los referendos dones zaporiya
y gerson ahora el siguiente paso es
unirse a Rusia algo que lo
representantes de las zonas no han
tardado en pedir estimado Vladimir
Vladimir
le pido que considere la cuestión de que
la República Popular de lugans pasa a
formar parte de Rusia
la legitimidad de estos referendos ha
sido puesta en entredicho por Ucrania y
sus aliados occidentales ya que se
producen en plena guerra pero a pesar de
las críticas al proceso los observadores
internacionales que se desplazaron a la
zona han dado validez a los referendos
democrático desde el punto de vista
democrático no tengo nada que decir en
contra de este referéndum
mientras que anunció que juzgará a los
colaboradores ucranianos del referéndum
como traidores por secundar lo que
tachan de fraude absoluto e injusticia
la participación es del 15 al 30% de los
habitantes de la ciudad y de ahí tomaron
los resultados cualquier matemático
diría que no es matemáticas sino
fantasía
en las zonas de los referendos como el
lugar muchos ciudadanos ven esperanza en
la anexión a Rusia
espero que haya paz y prosperidad espero
que la gente no se mate estoy orgulloso
de vivir en Rusia
ahora se espera que el presidente
Vladimir Putin anuncia la anexión de los
territorios en los próximos días y ya
advertido una cosa cualquier intento de
reconquista ucraniano será visto como un
ataque a ru